when you were here in october
i think you were just starting to get
behind the trump movement but at that
time was
at that time i wasn't sure at that time
he had you know they had maybe had one
or two debates
everybody was still saying this was a
joke i think i was still saying it was a
joke
it's clearly not a joke what is it
what's that great bob mark houseline no
one's laughing now
yeah but well actually we are you know
generation trump are having a great time
yeah you guys are having a great time
we're the only people who are
who are laughing um no when i did your
show and i did um joe rogan who's also
great
um i did his show and at that time i was
like well do i really want trouble in
the white house i'm not sure
right i'm not sure about that but i'm
enjoying the spectacle my views have
evolved
take me the evolution well you see i
care about all the things that you care
about
and i see the best way to accomplish
what we collectively want
um to throw our lot in with
um with the politician that
doesn't look like the rest of them that
it terrifies the rest of them i mean the
prospect of a trump candidacy the
prospect of trump
presidency terrifies not just liberals
but conservatives too because he
threatens to
blow apart the political consensus to
blow apart
i mean political correctness in
particular if you believe as i do that
it is one of the great cancers of public
life
there's nobody better situated to have
fun with that
than trump if you believe that um you
know not just the left but the right has
lost its way too
if you believe that you know wait let's
let's do one of these at a time so if
you believe that you want to just
blow the system apart you're the first
thing that you mentioned i'm an engine
of chaos i think they're all
am i allowed to say yeah you're in you
could say whatever you're gonna say what
i want so you're like the joker
whatever batman in the movie right he
just wanted
to say that and then i started like that
[ __ ]
so you want to burn so basically you
would want to burn the system when i see
gop politicians telling cnn reporters i
think it was cnn you know
the public doesn't pick the candidate we
picked the candidate yeah i just think
to myself you deserve to
burn you know these people don't like
the public
they don't like their own electorates
and the republican party has
you know become as hostile to its own
base as
as liberals have always been they've
started talking about their own base in
the same way that liberals always have
um you've got national review publishing
disgusting things about
you know white working-class americans
just awful these people aren't going
away
and these people are angry and
frustrated and what's interesting about
trump i think is he's captured the
imagination of a
huge sway of the population um from
what you might call traditional trump
supporters you might you know the the
veterans uh you know the white working
classes who feel very disoriented by
this new globalized world and very
concerned about mass immigration for
wage reasons and for cultural reasons
too and their right to be considered so
those are just
that's both of those both of those
accounts but
and the question i always get asked and
i don't mean to disrespect that that
group at all because
that group is is is my readership and i
love them but people ask me why do smart
people work from what they mean is
whether people like us float trump you
know we're not so we're not supposed to
right we're not not you i mean obviously
not you but um why do people like me
vote
you know why would i vote trump why do
you know media types folk trump
and the the answer to that is he
represents the best hope we have
of smashing political correctness apart
of
breaking open you know all of the taboos
the things stuff you're not supposed to
say
allowing real debate to be had again
today it is impossible in america to
have an honest discussion about the wage
gap
about the you know whether or not men
and women get paid uh different amounts
of money
we won't get into that today but well we
can use radical islam as a more
relevant example you can't have an
honest discussion you would lose your
job or you wouldn't get invited back
you'll never get a column at national
newspaper
the the overton window is so narrow and
pushed so far to the left
that something big has to happen a big
tumultuous event
needs to happen and i believe that that
event is a trump presidency because i
think it will destroy the republican
party they will never win another
election which is what i want
and i think the same thing will happen
on the left too with some you know the
saunders hillary kind of
tearing oh it's coming on the left what
i want yeah and i think this might be
what you want
what i want is a sort of new political
realignment on libertarian authoritarian
lines rather than left and right
and i want a new consensus to emerge of
disaffected liberals classical liberals
um you know dissident minorities like
gays
um you know small state conservatives
libertarians people who basically want
to be left alone
people who believe that government
should have some limited functions
but our culture should not be policed
our language should not be pleased we
should be able to do
be say think and act exactly as we
please
now i believe there is a majority in
this country who would get behind
that sort of cultural insurgency and
this election
is the first election in american
history that is being fought not on
uh foreign policy and not on economics
it's being fought
culturally it's been and it is being uh
it has been excited
it has been stirred up by a cultural
figure by a reality tv star
by uh you know an american icon yeah um
i've come around to believe that
actually having trump in the white house
would be wonderful and if he
finds himself in the white house and
isn't able to achieve very much aside i
mean he's going to daddy's going to
build a wall
and daddy's going to fix trade and
that's going to happen if then things
start locking up
because he's got a non-compliant you
know left and right
in all of the various machinery of
government i don't see that as a
particularly bad thing
one of the best presidents in history
was coolidge why because he did
absolutely nothing
um you know having some having like a
coolidge with bluster would be no bad
thing
and all of the criticisms that are
normally leveled at trump all of the
stuff that people say is clownish and is
populist i don't see those things
as intrinsically um anti-presidential
i mean in fact presidential material is
very much in the in the eye of the
beholder and clearly there are enough
americans who do believe
um that trump is presidential what's
really exciting about trump is that he
is to the same
in the same way that we are i think and
i definitely am um
trump is a direct creation of the
progressive left
he has been brought about he exists
because of the people that we both hate
so i'm with you there i've been saying
for a long time i have
bullied and policed and and harangued
and hectored and name-called for so long
they've told people that they're they
are um homophobes when they're not they
tell people they're sexist when they're
not they tell people they're racist when
they're not they tell people they're
transphobic and they don't even know
what that means
you're bringing out all the happy heavy
weapons here to to bring me over because
i get this you're going to the things
like
but this is exactly i don't care i don't
care i have one
it's the left because i didn't want this
to happen well it's too late now buddy
so um you you know either get on the
train or
you know who cares okay so what do you
not see
some risk even if i grant you all that
and you you say a lot so
you seem questioning in order to seem to
have you seem to have grown even if i
grant you all of that do you think that
there's some risk that by
unearthing all of the
the ways we speak to each other again
say this as the most
pro-free speech person there is i am
definitely now
seeing a real current of racism rising
up a real current
of of really hating muslims of really
hating jews that really no no
i mean i'm seeing it bubble up on social
media i don't know you're misreading the
situation
so so how am i misreading that well uh
you see
are we not worried about this stuff
bubbling up it isn't bubble it isn't but
it's always been
there it's always there you know people
have prejudices about people sometimes
those prejudices
are right uh when i was speaking at um
uh rockers somebody's
you know one of the one of the students
asked well you know there are studies
that show that white people think black
people are loud and obnoxious
you know and that's racism or maybe
that's a cultural thing black people do
use language differently and they just
couldn't wrap their head around the fact
that a prejudice might be right now it's
what you do with that sort of assumption
or prejudice or whatever
that uh that matters okay it may be that
um look two things to say on this right
one is um there's no hatefulness
and racism and sexism and homophobia
left in this country really
most of the expression of that kind of
stuff is driven
by the left um when it it sort of
you know so you know they go they go
they go looking for for
um homophobia they call around all these
you know bakeries in
the midwest or whatever finally they
find somebody who says no we'd rather
not do a lesbian wedding like guys we
found some homophobia
excellent you know they go all in on it
right it makes me want to go out and
bash
queers when i see you know i'm so angry
about it because it's just such
obvious bollocks now the second thing
and you know when you police down
like crush people it creates it creates
exactly what you're claiming that you
are looking for and that's the sort of
kafka-esque self-professional cycle of
the left now the second thing
and they're also using it specifically
to attack christians in this case
right because you wouldn't go to you
don't see them going no it's
psychological
they're not interested in the bigotry
they don't care about fixing bigotry
they care about hurting christians and
ridiculing christians
that's all true too the second thing is
you're you say you're
seeing all this stuff bubble up on
social media well let me take the the
ultimate example what remains the big
taboo in society which is anti-semitism
right most of the generation trump
the alt-right people the people who like
me they're not anti-semites they don't
care about jews they mean they may have
some assumptions about jews they may
have some prejudice about jews like the
jews run everything
well we do the jews run all the banks
what we do the jews are on the media
well we do
you know i mean they're right about all
that stuff now what you do with that is
the issue but the reason they go on
i don't even know where to start with
that so just go we do it's a fact this
is just
this is not in debate it's a statistical
fact you know the jews are almost to the
banks
jews completely dominate the media
vastly disproportionately represented in
all of these professions
that's just a fact it's not
anti-anti-semitic to point out
statistics
um but you know you seem to have you
know you you've missed
what what you agree with me on feminism
like it's not sexist to point out
statistics i'm suggesting to you it's
not you know it's not anti-semitic to
point out that these things are true now
the anti-semitism on the internet which
is really important i want people to
understand this because nobody seems to
when jonah goldberg of uh you know
national review or whatever is is
bombarded by um you know these memes of
like you know
whatever it is yeah um and you know
anti-semitic you know take a hike
and all this kind of stuff it's not
because there is a gigantic outpouring a
spontaneous outpouring of anti-semitism
from 22 year olds in this country
um what it is is that it it's a
mischievous dissident
um you know trolley generation who do it
because it gets a reaction
right that's been the case for young
people for generations it's just that
now they have access to things that
really get under people's skin and
internet scale
economics and uh and uh you know viral
dynamics
right um and they can get to people in
positions of power and people in
positions of power keep
biting and they keep taking the bait
that you know look
if you so that ex that sort of explains
this is what i said at the beginning of
the show that you're sort of a micro
trump to me because your rise has been
i know you want to think you're bigger
than trump but you're not no no no no
no no no no no look everybody everybody
has everybody's daddy to somebody
right i'm very happy for trump to be my
daddy and i'll be daddy to you know
everybody else but basically what you're
saying is that
they're using they're just using the
tools to get
people angry and then it causes another
reaction and then there's another
reaction
and that is what it's trolling and this
is a direct response to the language
policing it's a direct response to
people being told they can't say things
what do you got to remember about the
millennial generation um and and my fans
run as young
i get more from 13 year olds right these
people don't know what the holocaust was
they don't know they don't have any
living relatives who were in it
they in many cases don't even really
remember 911
you know they haven't lived through
these big traumatic
events in world history they're just
trolling and they've recognized that you
know
saying stuff about jews gets on the
nerves of journalists and you can get
like
it's like i've seen that guy on fox news
he's on the tv and i just tweeted him
like this stupid you mean
look at him he's going [ __ ] he's
happy now he's so triggered you know
like
right and you know what it's fun it's
funny i find it funny
because once you recognize that it's not
really about the jew thing
it's about trolling and provocation um
and that's the thing that they've
identified works really well
you begin to when you look at it it
starts to make more sense you're like
yeah of course
yeah racism in this country i mean there
is no kkk what is it like a few thousand
members left that we're constantly told
white supremacy is a problem
there are no white supremacists there
are no white nationalists they're not in
the media they're not in politics
they're nowhere
you know that no purchase whatsoever no
influence nothing if there is
if there is a racially supremacist
movement it's black lives matter and
it's very well funded and it's massive
and it gets
fawning coverage from the media there's
no white supremacist movement in this
country
and what trump supporters primarily are
reacting to
is being lied to and lied about for
decades by the establishment
and for me trump is a very necessary
correction to that
he is part of the cultural libertarian
movement that
um you and i uh i think both would
identify with i would say he is the
you know he is the the ultimate icon of
that movement so basically you think
that nobody else could do this so i'm
with you on a lot of this because we do
we do meet in that cultural libertarian
space and i get the language stuff
and i and i get what you're saying about
the anti-semitism and all the
all of that stuff i really do i
understand that and that's why i never
attack people i
you know i try not to fight with these
people when they're attacking me on
twitter
they don't care about the subject
because because it's something that's 17
year old kid
right and the left uses this 17 year old
kid he's rolling on this and there's
evidence that there's some uprising of
anti-semitism are they nuts
right well the left doesn't do it with
anti-semitism because they're okay with
that they yeah they're fine with that
but they'll deal with everything else
right
they certainly do it with the
anti-feminism stuff they suggest that
there is this epidemic of misogyny and
they just
find a random tweet and they find all
these tweets from young boys you know
and see the young girls are
congratulated and applauded and
encouraged to be hateful toward men
right when they you know they can get
involved and kill all white men hashtags
masculinity so fragile you know i bathe
in male tears
you see teenage girls doing this stuff
and it's hateful and it's horrible and
they're going to be alone and miserable
forever because feminists have ruined
them right
um when men do anything remotely similar
you know they will come in for the most
appalling censure they get suspended
from school
this is why girls sweet under their own
names very often partly because they you
know many of them are being trained into
being cry bullies they're being trained
into being um
you know into putting provocations out
there and then squealing you know
victimhood they're being treated
the girls are being taught the
victimhood and grievance culture is the
way to get what you want if you have no
talent
um they're being trained you know into
into all of this stuff boys on the other
hand very often are anonymous they like
pole on you know they're like 4chan
they're like all these places where they
can go let off steam and
get get all that boyishness uh
boisterousness out of their systems
which is a perfectly normal healthy
thing to do this is where they would
also play video games and get some of
that aggression out
and not you know and then and then you
know they call each other [ __ ] and
whatever i mean can you imagine what a
career i could have made
out of you know being offended by the
word [ __ ] yeah you know
no i wrote a column saying i want [ __ ]
gay and queer to be in i mean common
usage that's how you take the power away
from these words if you believe they
have power
not banning them elevating them up into
into these you know these
these taboos so i wrote this column i
said i want i want gay to be restored to
it's real like so it's prestige meaning
i mean you know the real meaning of gay
is like crap rubbish
[ __ ] lame hillary supporting immigrant
loving you know like that's what gay
means
it's not in the dictionary yet but i'm
sure they're getting around to it yeah
you know this is what i want gay to me
when so you know somebody says something
stupid i want you to be able to say
that's gay you know
or stop being a [ __ ] it doesn't mean
anything well these people aren't
homophobes
they do it because it gets to you and if
there are any journalists watching this
please
just learn this lesson well it does show
you how pervasive the ideology is
this controlling ideology because i see
even now when i'm with
just some of my gay friends who are
supposed to be the most over the top and
not politically correct and all that
and actually they've become numb
politically correct
but that's but so that's what this goes
to what i was saying earlier that in a
way this ideology what it wants
is not you because it doesn't want you
as the individual it wants you as the
collective
and then once again it wants you as the
identity
as the identity right so you're black or
you're gay or you're a [ __ ]
and he wants to put you in that bucket
and tell you what you're supposed to
believe about things and tell you
how to get what you want even if you're
not prepared to work and you have no
skills
um because you can just pretend to be
offended about things and you'll get on
tv
yeah they want you as they want you as a
bucket and and gay men
have fallen for this hook line and
sinker
they're really [ __ ] up um and but
fortunately there is an awakening in the
gay community there is something
happening and there is something
happening among gay people that i've
noticed at dinner parties
and i've noticed it in on social media
there's something happening with gays
they're beginning to recognize the left
is not their friend they're beginning to
rediscover the virtues when we were
talking in the last show and i said you
know one of the great things about gay
life is
you can be you can be outrageous and
diff and different and you can
topple out of a club on you know a
monday afternoon like drugged off your
face and you know with a [ __ ] in every
orifice
you can do whatever you can do whatever
you want and it's that's it it's that
bit of gay life
that um creates all of the artists and
inventors and geniuses is why we're so
overrepresented and all the people that
shove society forward right
that's the kind of gay life that i like
that's the kind of gay life that i
celebrate that's the kind of gay culture
i think is valuable
and gay people are starting to
rediscover this because they're starting
to realize the left is not their friend
that feminists don't have their
interests at heart
that in fact they're and they're
fundamentally hostile to many of the to
many of the things that make being gay
great right so for the
for these guys for for gays lesbians
whatever
when they see the left defending
islamism
and they go wait a minute i could be
that these people want to throw us off
roofs and put us on cranes in 11
countries like what are you
doing and then for some reason guilty
leftists feel the need to defend this
idiot so um how can you how can you
support this
how can you support this i mean you know
they want that what they want
is for us they expect us to believe
that above gay people above women above
blacks
i mean the blacks is the worst thing
right i mean they actually
you know there's one group of people in
this country who have genuine grievances
um who to whom something is still owed
and that's the black community right
there is a legacy from slavery i don't
happen to believe that black lives
matter is the answer because i think
it's hateful and divisive and the only
real result of black lives matter is
black cities in flames
wait let's not gloss over that because i
think people are going to are going to
try to gloss over you just said
you're saying that the that the black
community does have legitimate
grievances it does you were brought here
by and large as slaves
of course and then the first course
would anybody ever suggest otherwise
well i think a lot of people would say
uh
you know if you're against black lives
matter you're against nobody's done more
for the black community than me
um normally on my back but um the the
issue is that the issue is very
straightforward um you know black lives
matter is a hateful supremacy
organization
um insofar as it's organized at all it
is
you know it's it's a movement of black
supremacy um it's a bad thing
but this is what the left you know this
is what the left likes to do like divine
people
i forgot what we were talking about okay
so bringing this all back to trump
so what i haven't heard you say is
anything related to policy
but before i even let you answer that i
think what you're just saying is
it's completely irrelevant that's what
you're saying that this movement
has nothing to do it's not a political
movement in that there's no
there's nobody to take trump's place
after right if trump became president
via via all of this stuff all of this
cultural stuff
he's a president
today i'm going shopping put your
comments in the box
see you later but what you're talking
about is a cultural revolution not a
political revolution so that's
interesting because bernie
who's talking a lot about flip the
system and our systems corrupt and money
and politics the same thing
he's talking about a political
revolution and basically you're saying
forget that yeah because he's
because because he's an idiot and he's
20 years out of date that would have
worked before when people were upset
about you know economics
upset about foreign policy and politics
and even worked 10 years ago the iraq
war
now this war is cultural there's a
cultural war and there's only one
candidate for president fighting this
war culturally and it's trump
he doesn't care too much whether he is
occasionally inconsistent on policy
because he understands that nobody else
does either
and he's very so is that that's a sad
thing no no that's sad
you know what i'm sad about it no no i
studied politics sad over here
why did you study politics you know
um one look he's made two very clear
statements one is that he wants to build
a wall and that's emblematic
of what he you know believes about
immigration and you know the and
illegal immigration in particular they
can come over as he says but they've got
to come over
legally um which in and of itself isn't
racist right
i'm willing what's racist about that
well people keep yelling another race
mexicans aren't under the race they're
why aren't they yeah
well they're white because you americans
have this sort of hispanics they're very
confused
well you try to you try to invent like
divisions between people so that
anything anyone says about anyone can
somehow be called racist i mean
hispanics are why aren't they i'll bring
the chart next time i don't want to get
bogged down this is a youth thing not a
mean thing you know you people you
people make these rules up
we just have to live in it and live in
your world yeah um
i mean no of course it's not racist what
he's what he's saying is that there is
um
you know and in fact of course his his
concerns
about immigration benefit the black
community more than anybody else because
when
new hispanic immigrants come in it's
black wages they depress not
not primarily necessarily white wages by
the way barack obama said something to
that effect when he was running for
president the first time
yes he's done so much for the black
community i mean racial
racial harmony uh in america now you
know such a lovely thing eight years of
obama don't we all just love each other
after eight years of obama
no he's been the uh he has been the most
disastrous president for blacks in
so is that is that obama's biggest
failure then that he came in
with the political and cultural
revolution right it was political
and it was cultural it had both elements
to it but what he's going to exit with
regardless everything comes in
everything is worse and everything is
worse as a result of him
well the economy's got worse right the
american economy is better
right now than it was well okay but
i mean you give me so look gays can get
married i know you're not a big
proponent no
i wish they would stop i know but i wish
they would see the name of it
getting married you're going to have
your ruining you know they don't work as
hard because they're all interesting oh
no
all of that come over michael cook for
you
you can have all that god's sake but i
know you're for equality so i know
you're okay with it ish
ish but ish so is that really his
failure that at
when he leaves this thing after eight
years what could be ushered in after and
not that it's purely his fault but what
could be
ushered in after is going to be a
complete flip of the system
i i don't know that sounds that sounds
good to you so it's not a failure
well no i mean i i don't live in
exciting times when pretty much everyone
in the country wants the establishment
to suffer
pretty much everyone in the country
hates journalists hates politicians
hates the
you know the more they find out about
what their kids are being taught at
college
largely thanks to me i think um they
hate that too and
um we live in exciting times people want
to tear the system apart they want to
rebuild the system
in a different way i've suggested that i
quite like to do it along
authoritarian libertarian lines because
i think that makes more sense the way
people communicate these days and
people's priorities i think people are
more interested in culture than
economics
in this election um that's the sort of
realignment i want it may look very
different
um i what i like about
daddy i like about trump is that he
is introducing an element of realness
and an element of fun
and mischief into an arena in which into
into public life
which is an arena in which there has
been so little
freedom and joy for so long
that he's a necessary correction you
know so they can't make jokes on tv
anymore life isn't fun anymore
as a journalist like if i were a regular
journalist right and i'm not a regular
journalist because i work at a wonderful
place
while it lets me do you know outrageous
and crazy things
and obviously now i'm becoming this sort
of media figure i've got more license to
to to do stance
if i'm a regular journalist i'd be so
and and
i mean i know you know dozens of them i
know doesn't it's a miserable life
there's something you can't say
you can't tell the truth you can't tell
facts because somebody somewhere will
get upset you know you can't
say facts because journalism has become
now more about virtue signaling to
you know your fellow uh reporters than
telling the truth about what's actually
happening right so i got into a big
fight with a buzzfeed guy this week
because they wrote a piece about the
regressive left yeah claims sweet joke
and i have a soft spot for joe bernstein
so i don't even want to give him any
extra cred right let's not we don't have
to waste any
set and even name him yeah that's what
the left does you see this is what the
left is what the left does to anchor
okay so you want to name
somebody's wrong talk about it well
shine the light on it so yeah so this
guy
your your progressive your natural
progressive tendencies just slipped out
all right so this one you want to put
him under the carpet
here why are you censoring burns joe
bernstein from
i want the full light of scrutiny on
everyone i disagree with so that other
people can see they're wrong too
so this guy basically wrote a piece on
board this week
yeah is it joel
you once called me a cultural librarian
yes i did because you're a [ __ ]
because you're a person yeah i'm just
not that angry i'm not i like that
coinage because i'm a cultural
libertarian and because he's never
got the balls to say what do you really
mean he's not about bothering him i
called him a cultural librarian i
thought it was great
all right yeah well you just went
straight back to the [ __ ] reference
section
all right so joe burns joe bernstein
from buzzfeed
calm basically saying that uh you know
majin noise and sam harris and a few
others bill mark you know created this
regressive lesson but
really what the regressive left thing is
about is about alt-right hate and those
are the people that have made it a thing
where i know and every instance of it on
twitter and everywhere else
is because of the few people that are
left on the left like myself
who have tried to make it into something
now again that sounds like insider
baseball stuff but it's not annoying
about that but he wrote a piece about me
that was wrong too what i did
i see you are like you know oh don't
mention his name
what i did instead was i challenged him
to debate me i said debate me i'll give
you five thousand dollars rock up one
hour debate me you're wrong
prove it prove your case yeah scurried
into a hole
scurried into a hole um they actually
went up to 65000 now to be fair to joe
bernstein of buzzfeed and joe seen a
buzzfeed um
bernstein on twitter there you go okay
there we go to be fair to him since then
we've we've worked together and and
you know on pieces he's broken some news
for me and and he's been
he's been very fair and very reasonable
um but he was wrong about that and
refused to debate because he knew he
couldn't um defend his arguments
uh the same thing i think applies with
you too um
i don't think he would be able to defend
his position on that piece which was
obviously garbage
well i tweeted at him they all got
hundreds and thousands of responses to
him and he ignored all of it of course
yeah and i i don't think he'd show up to
debate you either but you should
if you'll lend me the five well i won't
need it because i'd win the debate so
um no you can't have any money but it
goes right but it goes to the i feel
like shapira now why do you
have money with your guests was it on
your show you asked about what she was
worth or when she earned or something
like that well i wanted him as a uh
as a one percenter to to tell people how
much he uh i didn't want a number i
wanted i said i could give you a number
right
he didn't he didn't but he said he's in
the over 400k i guess
situation who isn't yes um
go ahead oh really yeah if i should
write to larry i know it's uh
i gotta talk to harry kane i'll make a
note of that